but right before goose walks in during
the commercial break mark goes hey we
could talk about it on the air if you
want but I'm friends with Jerry Seinfeld
now I don't think what yeah it was just
a happenstance Bennington six months ago
was like I talked to Jerry he's a fan of
yours he caught you on The Tonight Show
and I was a guy right blow me you're old
you're overweight you're anything what
no I didn't buy it so one of those
things what you want it to be true so
bad like what are you [ __ ] with me
yeah give me chef you know so I didn't
believe it and then he went to Gotham I
run in there like slow down Seinfeld's
on you're gonna be waiting a while so
you're like a damn so Seinfeld comes off
and I'm going on next to gotta follow
him and I go hey big fan or no I go hey
still got it
probably it's probably good for him to
hear he's probably worried about true by
the way what does he still have it
he killed high is what Ron said true I
go on have a great sex I'm just booming
with confidence and I get off stage and
I go well that was fun now log to my I
had like three other shows that night so
I'm kind of in that mode of like get to
my show schedule what train am I taking
and he pops out of the shadows and goes
that was great
let's go talk and I was like that I'm
blanking I'm freaking out yeah
unfortunately you couldn't go because
you had other senses that's not right
well so we got out of the green room and
we you know for you keep slipping out of
Neal Brennan had a great quote he said
hanging out with famous people is like
driving next to a cop
you're like is this how I am am i normal
now is this what I'm like great [ __ ]
Jota whoa great analogy totally yeah so
you're doing that the whole time and you
kind of slip in and out of normalness
and then freaking out what night league
was this is like a like a Wednesday or
Tuesday and I go back out and watch his
set he had some great stuff and he had
one joke that was obviously new and not
fleshed out yet and I was a ghoul I'm
gonna think of some stuff for that you
know I know I know so you know he
finishes he leaves and he's talking to
Mazzilli on the sidewalk the
owner of Gotham and I run bikes I got to
get to my shows and I go hey great
talkin here great to meet ya and I say
it as I'm walking and I go I got a I got
an idea for that cemetery bit and he
goes on alright yeah take it easy and
you know that was the end of it and I'm
I'm clicking my heels I'm on seventh
Avenue going oh my god it's crazy I'm
whistling Dixie I'm kissing women the
whole thing and I leave the night I tell
the girlfriend I get home we make love
the whole thing break up yeah yeah the
next day we're sitting in her underwear
watching Seinfeld on Hulu and I get a
text from him his name pops up I show
her she's going oh my god this is crazy
we're jumping up and down their
underwear you're really overreacting
yeah that's exciting texted me and he
goes what do you got um cemetary bit so
you said I got this is very unlike me
but I got just a fire up my ass and I
was just [ __ ] it and I just wrote hey
Jay hey Jer yeah I said hey Jer I'm
jonesing for that hang let's talk wanted
to make it happen I just I was in the
Buffalo Airport IRA I just push send I
was alone I was on the road I think
that's actually smart let's take my
number I want to hang that's fine be
yourself but hey Jer I'm jonesing for
that hand jobs and stuff right now Jones
is no good yeah it's insensitive towards
heroin addicts I feel like that's the
main problem I would never want to get a
text from a comic that said I'm jonesing
for that hang no it's so what did he
respond with he goes he wrote something
back he wrote back like in ten minutes
okay very good he wrote back like oh
yeah okay okay let's do it I'll set
something up
and then nothing you got let it go you
should let it go write something else to
like man I'm standing here I feel like
you're lame dancing that's not bad
three weeks is nothing one more Jim and
Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM f
[Music]